hello there how are you got the whole
family here congratulations on your
honor tonight how does that feel to be
getting the the big award surprise it
you know I can't believe that much time
is still young and I feel to be here for
your brother tonight I think it's so
exciting our whole family is really
happy for them we feel very much my mom
and dad spirit here with us tonight
they'd love lemon he's the guy who
taught me how to do all this oh yeah
that's nice when you give the brother
the credit it's so wonderful to work
together and Fabulous Baker boys such a
great time what would you say is your
biggest accomplishment probably doing
stuff outside the movies you know like
doing stuff up within in the environment
and ending childhood hunger and stuff
like that yeah I think one of the things
that the movies have given me is a
certain degree of celebrity and I could
lend that celebrity to making the planet
a more beautiful place to live
well said right you realize who the
other recipients of this award are do
you know the last four recipients let me
name him for you
Oprah Meryl Streep Denzel and George
Clooney some good company that make you
feel even better
smiling with that list right now
what have you got left that you like to
do oh well it brought me a couple more
movies I'd like do something with my
brother you know you filmmakers out
there send us your stuff good stuff I
can hear the offers coming in right now
now that you said what would you like to
do what kind of movie would you like to
do together we're working on a script
right now called the Baker boys go to
Hawaii
this could Steve Clovis back is a direct
congratulations fantastic very deserving
so nice to see you beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]